than minam wrists hello everybody
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua fields Melbourne and I am Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists welcome to Episode one two
three one two three man this must be
like the perfect episode for you it is
it is the perfect episode one two three
have you ever seen the the OCD cowboy
right No
Oh was it Simpson Co was shooting up in
there so the running joke between me and
Ryan for the longest time is is that we
are one of us is OCD that's me one of us
is a DD and it's like the perfect little
reason Ryan I brought this video spinner
for you so we don't do any interviews on
this podcast but occassion let me bring
some friends in to talk about some stuff
and since this is episode one two three
we thought we would talk about hobbies
today and we have a friend of ours Paul
Johnson you may know him as Canyon City
or at least his music as Canyon City
he's here today to chat with us about
hobbies how you doing fall I'm doing
great thank you guys so much for having
me dude thanks for being here we tried
this before in Washington DC where when
Josh got sick and now here's the thing
man
yes I think that we probably could
rename the minimalists the Josh and Ryan
show so when you remove with Josh or
Ryan from the show it really creates a
much different dynamic now I think I
totally held it together when Josh got
sick and wasn't able to join us in DC I
think the crowd had a great time it was
a very unique experience for sure but uh
you know I'm not I don't I don't want to
put that episode out personally I just I
need you man I need you Josh I think the
good news is we can edit it down so
there there are certainly some Nuggets
in there they're gonna add value to
people's lives and I think what we'll do
yeah Paul did great
we also had Cal Newport there and who is
just one of my favorite sort of public
thinkers right he's a computer scientist
from Georgetown and so I think what we
can do is chop that up get get the the
the bits that are interesting in the
wide value to our audience and we can
really set for our patreon folks as a
patreon exclusive only some nuggets in
there for sure yeah so and plus Paul you
played some some great songs you you
played my favorite song of yours that
night and what we can dive into your
music here in a second before we've got
some questions today from some folks
about hobbies and now people hear that
word hobby and and they'll think that
sometimes it's a stepping stone between
something I enjoy doing something maybe
I'm interested in and a career and I
think we can parse that out a little bit
today for some people that may be true
and they may mean you turn your hobby
into a career and that's what I thought
it'd be interesting to have you here
today because you have turned something
that was a hobby esque and and into
something that is your full-time gig now
and you play music for a living I do
yeah I'm very very fortunate lucky and
happy because that certainly is not
anything it's owed to me so it's a I'm
grateful every day I get to do it you
grew up in Fargo I did at Griffin Park
North Dakota one of our favorite cities
that's what I hear TED talk right yeah
we did that we didn't talk there we've
gone to a conference there a few times
and I did not I did not know Fargo had
so much culture man it's a great leader
did I know it's it's really grown and
last saw I left in 2008 okay I initially
had moved down to Nashville and under
the disguise of college which didn't
didn't quite take for me yeah me but uh
yeah but uh when i when i left i mean i
i think it's it's funny cuz like you
know people that grow up in nashville
have the same thing where they're they
they just want i think everybody wants
to make their own home somewhere and so
i think i had a little bit of that but
now when i come back and I visit I can
look at you know the old downtown and
appreciate some of the history there and
also see some of the ways that it's
growing and changing so it's definitely
there's there's there's a lot more there
than I think I gave it credit for
growing up but I was just so I just felt
so isolated and coal
ready to ready to run Josh now where
there was 2014 and they didn't even at
that point I don't think they really had
like a decent like coffee roaster there
at this point there's several great
cause I was gonna say this in the last
for just in the last four years yeah
there are several Coffee Roasters now
that are that are amazing they've got
breweries opening up left and right
Fargo it's a pretty pretty amazing city
if you all haven't visited it you have a
song that it reminded me of this because
I was listening to it and knowing the
context of someone so I was hoping to
talk about some of your songs today
because I think and I don't mean just to
blow smoke but I think it's true I think
you're one of the best just writers out
there in general your your music your
music said you do some things with your
music you'll have these little one lines
that that like fully encompass what I
try to write with an entire book and
like there's something that's beautiful
in in that brevity but you have this
song on your second album which is it
was every year I released my top 10 like
favorite albums of the year and your
album was my favorite album alive oh I
appreciate that was I was blown away
when I saw that cuz I know you guys you
know good stuff so I was I was honored
to be in that list and I have a fairly
eclectic taste of music you'll see like
yeah little peep on there and then also
you'll see can't yeah and we need to do
is the the the collaboration between -
yeah and so I I think what I notice on
on your new album it's called
constellation and you had the song it's
called for the day and there's this
little little it's almost like if you if
you weren't paying attention it's a
throwaway line sometimes you get you get
you through but you said the the summer
so long here and I'm like only a person
from Fargo is going anywhere outside of
Fargo if you're from Fargo right that is
one of the it's it's honestly I actually
appreciate growing up from Fargo for
that thing is like if I a lot of people
in Nashville like I miss the mountains
and I miss you know like this all the
stuff that I can do outside I'm like if
I see a hill I'm excited
like I'm just you know down so so for
those of you have not been to Fargo
which by the way our documentary when we
first finished the documentary the first
place we screened it not even the final
version the first place we screened it
was in Fargo North Dakota yeah we went
there the Fargo theater downtown we
filled it up with as many people that
could fit into the theater and we got a
ton of really great feedback and
actually helped us shape the documentary
and make it better so we have a certain
debt to Fargo and we've done several
tour stops out there yeah I probably
have more friends in Fargo than just
about any other city in the country
which is really weird because I've never
been there for longer than a week but
but we whenever we go like there's just
a lot of culture per capita there and
and once you once you sort of get in
with the community and I find that's
true anywhere you if you move to
Nashville I think it's it's certainly
similar there plus there's a lot of much
bigger music scene in a place like
Nashville or LA or New York or if you go
to Seoul or Tokyo Lee it depends on
where you go the big cities will have
what you want sometimes it makes a
little bit harder to find those pockets
but once you find them you can really
really get into them but we were lucky
enough first time we went out to Fargo
we found this this sort of pocket of
amazing creative people and
entrepreneurs and all kinds of people
and and so we keep in touch with a lot
of folks from from Fargo whenever
whenever we get a chance but it's so
cool so full circle I had no idea at the
documentary starts I mean I before I
knew you guys was a big fan of the
documentary and really got a lot a lot
from that and so that's so cool that it
comes full circle with the origin story
yeah you know so I hate telling people
what they're I I know really let me
rephrase that
real quick I hate asking musicians what
their songs are about because it's it's
one of the worst it's like it's like
almost a filler question right so what
did you have in mind
the song and it's like well and quite
often the song is ruined when you ask a
a musician to explain I think of this
Jason Mraz song Jason Mraz had a song
that's like about snuggling up next to
this this girl looking deep into my yeah
this really like sensual love song about
his girlfriend yeah and then at the
beginning the saw one of the live events
he goes I wrote this song about my cat I
think I just ruined this song for you
it's so truly it's a song about a cat
and I cool I'm like oh no like the
sensual song and you know I know he just
kind of likes hanging out with his cat
on up the cat lady demographic so I was
figuring instead of instead of asking
you what certain songs or what certain
music was about I was going through your
album and I thought maybe like I think
the nice thing about songwriter and even
writing books or even blog post doesn't
matter once you first sort of put it out
in the world it's less yours and it's
more of a collective thing I feel like
the people own it to a certain extent or
at least they own the meaning about what
what they can take away from it and so
for me you write some of these lines
that I just walk away from and I'm Leigh
huh I don't even know what that means at
first or wow that's exactly what I've
been trying to say
and so what make sure your music
different from me it's well first off it
sort of brought me back to this time of
like 2007 when I was just really deep
into singer-songwriter musical I was
really just digging into it but it
didn't your music didn't sound like
anyone else it just brought me back to
that same sort of mind frame where it
felt new again and something felt new to
me because there was this hopeful
maturity to your music that I don't that
I don't always hear in a lot of music
and a lot of sort of singer/songwriter
music where it's like you know I love
you in fact right or not Ryan and I will
joke about this sometimes where where
instead of it's like we get the worst
advice from pop songs right lay do like
that imagine dragons album was filled
with
worst advice like great songs but
terrible advice right yeah in your or
you know I can't take my eyes off of you
well yeah you probably should at some
point and like I just so it's so
unrealistic but but in in and it's
almost like this this and I can
appreciate it because you feel like that
in the moment sometimes like oh my god
I'd die without this person I remember
being 18 and like how am I ever gonna
live without this person and she broke
up with me and moved to Traverse City
Michigan I'm so I'm gonna drive the
Traverse City Michigan in this in the
winter snow snow to visit her inner baby
yes I'm speaking for a friend seriously
driving up to Traverse City Michigan and
like the snow is covering the stop signs
that's how like and I'm like what am I
doing here but it's like I can't and I
think a lot of songs are that it
captures that emotion but I'm older now
you know I'm 36 years old and and
there's a certain maturity that I've
realized that in a certain letting go
and the ability to to move on and you
have you have two albums out and and if
I were to describe those two albums that
the first one was midnight waves and the
reason that actually so he you were just
in London recently you're on tour you're
on tour right now we're fortunate enough
to go see you tomorrow night this will
actually this will be out not until
March I think March 13th I believe it is
so by the time this comes out Ryan and I
are having a grand time in Australia
that's right he's developing an accent I
was watching like some peaky blinders
before I went out to London so like I
want to get in the you know mindset and
didn't get the dialect in me you know
yeah it's it's funny my four-year-old
she got into this the stage where she
was watching this British cartoon called
Peppa Pig and she started developing a
British accent and she really likes
chocolate so if you would just come to
me and say hey can I can I have a box of
chocolates
well this you've been indoctrinated by
Peppa Pig but anyway I sent Paul a photo
a few weeks ago Sean was going out to
buy a motorcycle way out in Azusa
California and even though there was it
isuzu California birthplace of Tony
Robbins there and it's the Canyon City
and so I did took a picture and he's
like hey by the way I'm gonna be in Los
Angeles I'm like dude I know we've got
we've got front-row seats to the to the
show on Saturday night but anyway I I'm
thinking back to your music and and you
have these two albums I was dry we were
actually driving through Azusa listening
to midnight waves your first album just
totally coincidental and I look up and
Shawn looks up at the same time and it's
like Canyon City I look at my - and it
says Canyon City you know I got to take
a picture that sent it over to pull that
first album though it was like you were
obviously younger I mean you're always
younger on your first album than you are
your second sure unless well unless
actually here's a weird thing Ryan
Ryan's 14 episode one two three right
now right we are actually younger when
this episode comes out that's no I'm
sorry I'm sorry
we'll be older when it comes down yeah
we'll be older so every recording of us
is one more younger as everyone say yeah
what does everyone say look at this
picture of me when I was younger every
picture of but here's a weird think so
episode 122 we've tried to record twice
and we have failed so technically we are
gonna record the episode 122 after
webisode 123 if it works out in Twilight
Zone it's the worst episode of black
mirror ever and so I was I was listing
that album and and I was saying there's
a hopeful maturity to your music but
that that first that first time was like
now the word I wrote down well it felt
like you were you were searching for
hope or there was a hopeful searching in
the word I wrote down that I made up as
I often make up words was hope search
like I said I'm hopeful like you were
searching for for hope like there
say a hopefulness in the music but there
was also a searching I won't I won't go
to as far to say a yearning or a craving
because there was a maturity to the
music and into the lyrics but then on
the second album it was almost like the
hope was found and so the word I wrote
down was hope found and and as opposed
to hopeful and which it was hopeful but
like it like there was an increased
level of almost security maturity
thoughtfulness in the music and I was
hoping to talk to you about a few of the
songs a few of the lyrics that really
stood out to me instead of saying hey
what did you mean by this fine you're a
first single from constellation was a
song called our way am I correct in a
really good video for open a link to the
video the YouTube video in the show
notes for this and you had this this
line that really reminded me of my life
right now
you said cuz though I hate how it feels
I love the heartache that brings me back
to you and the site it's like this line
about separation and Becks and I met my
partner Beck's who you got to meet
briefly what while we were on tour and
she she has the we have a child together
but her biological father lives in
Montana still and so Beck's is sort of
between two world she's 50 percent here
50 percent of the time in Montana Ella
is back and forth like they just landed
yesterday we went to the beach
immediately like I get in all this great
time with them every other week sort of
thing right and but and I'll go back to
Montana occasionally and like but there
there is this distance and and in with
that distance sort of creates this this
this heartache right I love the
heartache that brings me back to you and
and in this line it was just like it
perfectly described like I want to write
a whole essay or do a whole episode on
this and I'm like I don't have to like
oh I have two lines here that can
perfectly describe and it's much better
in music because if I just if I were to
write these down and it is poetry but if
I just write it down it's beautiful but
but when you sing it it's it's something
else it it personifies the way that that
I feel and in it it's about this this
distance and closing the distance and
right I know you feel this way because
you're
extrovert and so when when we were on
the road in 2014 we did 10 months on the
road 119 events which is not impressive
to a musician because that's plenty
impressive oh that's incredible dude I
have a whole new level of respect for
touring musicians man lay guy yeah no
wonder no wonder most of them turned to
like hard drugs and alcohol
Paul is shooting up right now but here's
the thing we were gone for 10 months of
the year and it was right at the
beginning when you started dating Mariah
was you know six months before the tour
started or whatever maybe even less than
that and you you two had developed a
really good rapport really quickly but
then you had all this distance between
you for extended periods of time and
it's hard you because you don't want
that you want to be by her side you want
to be there you want to be able to to
have these face-to-face conversations
you want to be intimate but that
distance there also improve your
relationship in a different way
and what I found was with Rebecca and in
my relationship and even with Ella like
that distance that that's there makes me
it makes me appreciate those moments
when they come back and I think we lose
that appreciation sometimes so for me
that the this song or especially this
line was about it was about the
appreciation or the ability to
appreciate the time that we have
together and not taking that for granted
and there's there's a certain type of
gratitude in that yeah it's a I feel
like in the absence of a person
sometimes all you have is the sting of
that missing but but because that's
still something you have you can't
cherish it yeah and and so I think that
like for me sometimes you know the sad
song is exactly what I want to hear is
because it's even though it's it hurts a
little bit it's it's you know coattail
of that thing that you wish was right
next to you and so it's um it's it's a
weird it's a weird you know kind of a I
don't know what the juxtaposition I
suppose of
Hertz but but you don't want to stop
yeah that's that's a great way to put it
there's a line in Jonathan Franzen's
book a freedom I don't know if you've
read it but it's it's a phenomenal book
it's I think it's the Great Gatsby of
our generation yeah it's it's a great
book but there's one of the main
characters his name is Richard Katz and
he's a musician and a really talented
musician but then he like sort of gets
this Fame and like Grammy nominations
and all this stuff and realizes like I
love this but I also hate it and and I
this to me that's almost oh you're
talking about like I love this but I but
I hate it I hate this but I also love it
and and that sting you talked about like
it stings being away but yeah the thing
about your music that's different is you
don't wallow in it you it's not like
wallowing and sorrow like I need another
drink and although you have lines like
that there's a line about you know this
this this isn't sober but it sure isn't
straight right and and and and so I
think you can you can feel the pain you
can feel being in the valley Ryan and I
we just did an episode about emotions
what we tried to do no we did the
emotions episode well that one's good
too
we did one and then the second one
uh-huh yeah and the second one went
great but we had the first one Ryan just
wouldn't stop crying throughout the
whole pond stop recording Ryan is the
it's the head in the heart the head and
the heart of the duo here and and and
I've found that there's both of that in
your musical I somehow you're able to
encompass both like it's not just it's
not just like oh my goodness like I've
that my life is over I mean I see that a
lot in songs and they're beautiful songs
and I love listening to them but at some
point it's like okay like I need some
hope in this this is this is raw despair
one of my favorite musicians is Damien
Rice and I love his music and and but
there is so much despair on especially
the first two albums the third one like
Adele's album like the one that really
set her off would ya we're just filled
with the spare yeah yeah I'm sorry but
what were you sayin rises up well I mean
that there
is this it almost vassalage between
despair and anger and then anger for the
despair and then you despair because
you're you can't get rid of the anger
and it becomes a vicious sort of crazy
eight cycle but with your music I think
there's when I talk about the maturity
like there's a certain letting go so
that same song we're just talking about
it our way you said when the flood comes
rising there's nothing to hold and and
and and I can imagine that like the the
flood in Houston recently like literally
we had this this girl who she sent Ryan
this private message and she had water
past her ankles right almost up to her
knee and she was holding a copy of our
book minimalism live a meaningful life
and she's like you have no idea how much
this is helping me to let go right now
because she's literally standing her
house with and and and how do i how do I
write an essay about that right it's
gonna take me it's gonna take me four
thousand words to do it but you can do
it in like eight words and and and well
I mean in but I think so literally we
can see the flood right but then
figuratively I mean obviously this line
highlights something's figurative like
when there's a flood are you gonna go
back and try to grab every trinket are
you going are you gonna try to deal with
the unimportant stuff and and I tried to
do that a little bit with the book that
we wrote everything that remains in a
documentary there's a whole thing where
I'm like Rome was burning but there's
still time for shopping at IKEA and and
and and it wasn't it wasn't a people
often think that's like me dissing IKEA
or something it's not it was me I was
the problem IKEA wasn't the problem it's
like I still get some stuff from Ikea
occasionally it's okay but but I had my
whole life crumbling around me but my
marriage was ending my my mom just died
I'm trying to work out our funeral
arrangements and and the best thing I
can think of doing is like let's go
shopping for furniture and and all of a
sudden it's like well Rome was burning
and and I'm stuck here and and what
you're saying there is hey this flood is
rising are you gonna worry about are you
gonna worry about the nonsense I think
we get stuck and the nonsense
it's
absolutely I mean it's something that
been I've never been folds on if you
guys are fans of his he's a I was
reading some interview a long time ago
and he says something that I've always
resonated with the bushes just he can't
he basically said like I don't connect
with a sad song that sounds like a sad
song or a happy song that sounds like
ever I was like that that space of
dissonance it's kind of where he likes
to live and I I'm very much both as a
fan amis again and a greater - I very
much relate to that and that I think
that's just a more accurate reflection
of life is there's always some
dissonance and just sort of allowing for
for that to be okay I think that a lot
of us had a good conversation of someone
last week where we're talking about how
I think that there's a perception - that
there's gonna be like a point at which
everything is okay you know that we're
gonna be like if I can only achieve this
much or get this much or or get past
this line that there there's like a
point where I've sort of solved the
Rubik's Cube and everything from here on
else is just gonna be flowers and I
think the reality is everybody is always
gonna have a little bit of dissonance
there's always gonna be the next thing
the next achieving there's always going
to be that that sense but that that's
just that's just being human and I don't
think we're here to be okay
totally and and so I I really resonate
with those points of kind of like happy
sad songs and sad happy songs where it's
a little bit of a wink to the other side
saying like you're welcome here too like
this this is you're part of this you
know without one you can't have the
other love Evan yeah I mean it's in what
we say it all the time it's impossible
to have the peaks without the valleys
for Sherman and that's that's a great
way of embracing it no I totally agree
man it's it is so important to accept
that we will never become this full
potential of ourselves and it's taken me
a long time to accept that and an
example of that is this podcast I feel
like we do a really good job with this
podcast I have a lot of fun doing it if
you were to tell me back in 2014
hey Ryan you're gonna start a podcast
that would have been this in the future
off into the distance maybe one day
thing it would have been a
it's stressful to thinking about
starting a podcast sure but now we're
here we're doing it it's great we're
having fun now it's like cool man let's
move on to the next thing let's let's
see if we can you know make another
documentary yeah and I think that having
having that approach with life it
definitely helps us
I don't know prevents prevents a lot of
like angst and letdowns I think because
I know you know I'm probably not the
only one who beats myself up when life
doesn't go exactly how I expected to
what's that is just you it's just knew
it I knew it was just me well here's the
thing so we've spent the last five
minutes talking about this sort of the
The Marriage of angst and being okay
with the angst but but so my favorite
song yours is a song called find you and
I just think it's it's like this this
just beautiful standalone piece of song
right it fits great on the album I'm so
glad you made it the second track on the
album it works perfectly there and just
the the way you you have the the album
arranged but but there's there's this
lyric on that song where you said just
be honest has it ever been fine and and
like just that one line there's a couple
lines before that what were you talking
about staring demons in the eyes and and
and and made a habit of looking past all
the white lies and then you say just be
honest has it ever been fine I remember
the first time I heard that I just I
just paused it oh there's this there's
this moment where it's like we're
searching we're trying to like make
everything fit just right once I have
the perfect coffee table once I have all
the appropriate decorations in my space
once I have this this and this once I
have the ideal partner and the
two-and-a-half kids and the dog and the
picket fence then everything is going to
be fine but once you get it and
literally I got it I had it at one point
I had a literal picket fence and there's
nothing inherently wrong with that but
it's not going to be fine because of
that it's fine because we can say okay
this is fine I can accept this for what
it is warts and all
that's that's really season that that
I'm currently learning a lot in which
I'm so happy to be like here with you
guys right now cuz I just like want to
you know absorb through osmosis you know
the the wisdom that you guys have to
share but uh it's it's really I mean I I
worked for a long time music's has
always been a goal of mine and and
something that I was really the core of
what I love to do but worked for a long
time a lot of different capacities in
trying to basically just spend as much
time as I could making music and then
Canyon City came on the heels of a lot
of learning about what I didn't want to
do within that and in some cases some
failures too well let's talk about that
okay so we're talking about hobbies
today and we're gonna answer some
questions for some folks I'm sure but
but you you started out music was
something that was I assume a hobby for
you at first when you were in grade
school when did you start playing music
started playing around seven or eight
doing musical family or I do em both
both my parents were in a folk trio
colleges era there it was always like
around harmonies were around and I
didn't realize that it was weird to have
you know like the family get together
and like sing four-part harmony until
you know in grade school and people like
Colin we don't do that but I was very
very lucky to have that and then had a
great guitar teacher when I was a little
kid although I was still kids I wasn't
you know I was born by no means the guy
that was like practicing you know ten
hours a day and and like it was it was
very gradual had I actually practiced
the way that people encourage you to
practice I should be a much better
guitar player right now but uh but it's
just been you know a long time playing
and just sort of a language that that
has always kind of been alongside Theo's
it was initially uh start writing songs
start my songs probably around middle of
high school maybe around 14 or 15 years
old okay
and now at this point yeah did you when
did you know you wanted to do more with
music was was it early or was it a while
or I think it was why I started as a
guitar plus like just in the you know
the high school garage bands and stuff
like that I was just the like the
electric guitar player and then
songwriting really happened when when I
felt like I had no other out
to express some of the things that
wanted to come out and so initially it
was just you know so well just trying my
hand at it and then that's I think I
think I always want played with the idea
of music being something I wanted to do
for a long time or maybe as a career but
once songwriting started to come and
that was really when like the bug bit
hard and it was it was something I
couldn't be without and so as a at that
point making it a career was was really
just was just finding a way to spend as
much time doing that as possible and and
it's the the irony is in chasing it I
spent a lot I'm 28 now moved to
Nashville when I was 18 yeah and he's
but you've been there since since you're
18 right yeah that's right yes so you
moved down there to go to school or at
least under the guise so that was the
Trojan horse to get you down exactly
yeah
but you started doing some music that
was outside of what you're what you
wanted to do yeah and and what it was
well if I made sure you just you just
talking about how you were chasing it
sure so if you can incorporate
continuing with chasing it in and in I
think that might you can tie that in
with answering his question as well sure
yeah well it was a so I was I was really
trying to turn it into I mean like just
try and like chase it as like a career
choice well yeah I think that I think
that you were getting ready to go
somewhere but chasing it and Josh's
question about how you kind of took this
different approach with music sure was
because of that chase that you put
yourself in am i off base with not sure
sure no it was definitely use it was a
kind of a pathway that I was I was set
on and trying to make just spend as much
time as I could with it but the irony is
that in doing that I I tried to do
anything I could that would get me
closer to music and essentially open up
more time to do that so when I was in
Nashville and I was early 20s I was you
know working a part-time job to make
ends meet and it and really just wanted
to you know make music whenever I could
and so I I was doing some session work I
was writing for some other people and
then there was a producer that on an
earlier project that was that was pretty
Canyon City running that stuff gave me
an opportunity to come and do some my
own songs which was
that was kind of the first reentry into
being an artist again so well you can
sing them and you always have even
though it's coming in as a session
guitar player I was always like
songwriting was always what I was doing
anyways but I did youdid you write songs
for other people I did nothing nothing
that's like blew up or anything like
that I mean the biggest thing that I
think I wrote that
well actually I ended up end up singing
out was result like some movie trailers
and stuff but like it was nothing that
was you know impressive by any means a
commercially fascinating because you you
have someone who's obviously a talented
musician guitar player incredible voice
but also I mean you to me your talent is
in the writing and and and it's what
other people want those all quite often
there no we just need a session guitar
player and we need you know so we need a
body to fill the seats was was there
ever a point where you were writing your
music not for you yeah absolutely and
and and that was that was where where it
really became clear to me what I didn't
want to do cuz I I knew that I wanted to
do music as much as I could but when
when that first project started to fall
apart just personnel-wise I was talking
with a friend of mine who runs a small
label and Nashville that's mainly does
sync work which is basically like music
for TV and film and that kind of stuff
and and I knew that you know my my heart
had always been and I was just going to
be in doing stuff that pretty much
Canyon City which is very it's just
expressive it's honest where I'm at it's
not necessarily - for any particular
purpose outside of laws what I feel or
this is what I want to say but that
particular project I knew was going to
be angled towards making music for
commercial purposes sometimes literally
for commercials like we did like some
pictures for like yeah that kind of
stuff and and so I knew that that was
gonna be a means to none but the goal is
to get out of the part-time job to be
able to make music a full-time job I did
- after deal with them and after the
first record I I felt so it hurts so
much to like basically what end up
happening was to make the thing that I
love my job
I turned the I turned the thing that I
love into Jess
another job it became another job that I
didn't want to go to but it was worse
because I also lost the thing that I
loved like I lost the reason I was
fighting it and it's not hard to do that
like it is it is a because we do look at
a job being a means to an end and there
are certain things I know I do it where
I start to compromise I'm like you know
what I really need to get eight hours of
sleep tonight yeah but we just ended
this event I just got back to the hotel
at midnight I got a flight at 6:00 a.m.
I'm gonna get I'm gonna get four hours
of sleep and there are things that I
will sacrifice a little bit and and I
think you for me I don't know how you
feel about this Josh but it is this
balance of what am I willing to
sacrifice how much am I willing to
sacrifice and when it comes to putting
food on the table and keeping a roof
over your head there's a lot of things I
do yes it to do that um and yet it's
it's very especially with a hobby it's
very easy to start to kind of go against
what what we know we want to do in order
to like try and make some money off of
it and and you know there's a question
in here about about making money off
your hobby and and that it's it's
certainly it's certainly okay to make
money off of an hobby but to make that
the main purpose there's the a qabil
yeah it get distorted a little bit as to
what I realized is in order for
ironically in order for this to be my
job which was the the the thing that
turned it into what I've been fortunate
to do full-time now for a few years was
Canyon City but in order for that to
happen it had to become my hobby again I
had to redefine so like I told the guys
like we have to renegotiate contract I
can't give you a second record it will
it'll kill me and so you but it was it
was because here's the other thing you
have people who were like now I killed
just to have that but yeah the problem
is once you get there you realize how
unfulfilled it is
you lose the thing that you love about
this is this is so good for our
questions yeah I think we should dive in
or avoid questions yeah because
otherwise this is gonna be another intro
we're gonna get tweets where people are
like can you please not make your
episodes three hours long and then we'll
have to explain to them that they can
just pause the episode I'm not gonna
explain it I would just block those
people welcome to Josh's block party all
right
still be alive by the way he's ready to
dive in Millie yeah let's answer some
questions we'll keep talking about
hobbies we'll talk about love and
passion and and everything you were just
talking about we'll try to apply it to
some of these questions our first
question is from Adam in Nashville the
big thing that I spend a lot of my time
doing is sports and I was wondering what
your guys philosophy is on like you know
materials that are required for sports
like I'm big into rock climbing and rock
climbing it requires a lot of material
so like what do you guys have to say
about decluttering when it comes to
sports because if I want to rock on I
still have to have all these materials
so do these add value to my life and if
not how do I get rid of them
Ryan the thing I wrote down when I first
listened to Adams question was free
climbing equals death people do that
that free soloing thing right where that
they just like get out there with no
equipment whatsoever and it is so
impressive you can find the videos on
YouTube or or you find the video like
people get really popular on Instagram
because we are a voyeuristic culture and
we're waiting to see like what happened
one hand slips and all of a sudden you
die and it's different I mean you might
break a guitar string oh it's pretty low
stats what I do I just get my feelings
hurt if I earn you know go too deep into
a love song
and I think if we have a hobby that we
really enjoy that there's going to be
some necessary equipment quite often now
here's the thing there's a difference
between necessary and unnecessary thank
you
essential and non-essential I think what
I was gonna say is necessary and fetish
like and you you're you live in
Nashville which is the the Music City
right and and there are a lot of people
who collect a lot of musical instruments
and other things they get no value from
whatsoever absolutely and it's because
it's a thing that they're supposed to do
and believe me I get it I had plenty of
collections we just did an episode about
collections recently right and we made
fun of like the signed Al Pacino scripts
that I had to do so Paul what is your
recipe for like not having this horde of
musical equipment because I'm sure and
correct me if I'm wrong I'm sure you
play other instruments besides the
guitar I do not not always well but I so
so how do you curate your collection
because uh I'm sure that you're not a I
know you're not a hoarder I try not to
be yeah it's I mean that there's
definitely the temptation to especially
you can justify it as a you know a
business expense so to speak you know
well I mean this from my job you know
and it's it's shiny and and it would
give me a sort of sting of happiness for
a second but uh what I find is and
initially this was out of necessity when
I couldn't really afford that much but
that limitation actually is a pathway to
a certain kind of creativity for me
yeah and so what all like in my home rig
would my studio all actually
intentionally buy gear that has like one
knob or you know that has has just a few
things and I'll try to cap what I would
when I edit meliss the reasons why oh
that's great I mean that's Josh and I
are huge on that with with limitations
breed creativity and what am I saying
your line right John I wrote it down I
wrote it down as constraints breed
creativity but it's it's the same thing
by having some sort of limitation there
you find your it makes your
line work in a way than if you had
absolute abundance I to me here wait
wait no hold on I just want to be clear
though we're not we're not challenging
the free climber to go with IC we're
trying to talk about a free clinic what
are the stakes is my question but yeah I
absolutely I think if you want to try
free climbing do so at your own risk the
the the inside joke among free climbers
isn't am I going to die at free climbing
it's when am I going to die right they
they know what's up like a very large
percentage it's it's the most dangerous
hobby or job in the world probably right
you see these guys hanging off mountains
with one hand and their massive forearm
right there and then all of a sudden the
rocker slit yeah the rock breaks you
have no control over there right and so
I think some equipment is necessary
especially in a sport like rock climbing
however when we look at something like
music I look at the abundance the
abundance mindset of if I just had
everything then everything would be
perfect yeah I often think of dr. Dre
who I mean you just often think of
doctor is the good doctor there you go
and but I start calling myself a doctor
no we already agreed that you were the
venerable Ryan that could be yeah that's
right you're one step away from
sainthood
anyway I noticed that light early on you
know he's considered to be you know if
not the best hip-hop producer of all
time certainly in the top five and and
had some certain constraints early on
right he had a few turntables a little
bit of equipment that was borrowed here
and there and created some of the the
most memorable most significant music of
the late 80s and early 90s and now that
he has literally everything he could
ever want he has the perfect studio if
you saw the Defiant ones this
documentary that was about him and Jimmy
Iovine in the music business and he's
building now his house over in Brentwood
like the perfect studios I just couldn't
find a studio that had everything that
Dre has released one album in the last
about 15 years well yeah himself right
and he does very little with other
artists too and I think that's that's
the difference and I think sometimes
what happens and he has become this
over-the-top perfectionist right yeah
and that's what everybody that whole
album the detox album because he
couldn't get it perfect right he worked
on for eight or nine years and like it
wasn't perfectly about it by then it was
dated and don't get me wrong I think Dre
is one of the most talented so crazy
music Minds right yeah it's just nuts to
me how the limitations bred this awesome
creativity you know late 80s early 90s
and now it's because he had no
expectations his standards were his
standards were high right but he all but
he had no expectations were now his
standards are high and his expectations
sounds like they're like higher they're
impossible so now his standards he can't
get to that level of standard to me
kicks well at least with that album well
and I actually struggled with that too
so Ryan and I finished the first draft
of everything that remains our third
book it was our second book sorry to
five years ago right and I can tell you
that like it was people asked how long
did it take you to write that book I'm
like it took 32 years right and I think
the first album is sort of that way
right well or for you I don't maybe was
the second album I don't I don't know
how it works but you're as good as what
your last creation was and sometime for
me the last I've had for fall starts on
a next book and it's because I felt so
good about that book and it was this
infinitely dense thing like I felt like
I said everything I wanted to say in
everything that remains and the next
book would just regurgitate the things I
had do I say it differently though I and
so I run to this prana know if you run
into that problem with some of your
music and you're trying to grow beyond
it but you're like to me I see someone
who makes an album like constellation
and I'm like well I thought I would just
check out at this point like I'm done
like I've created that album and
congratulations everyone you get to
listen to there are way too many singer
songwriters to do that and it makes me
so angry well Damien Rice was that like
yeah eight years my album I'm trying to
think like who there are some artists
that we like like these one EPS or these
albums that we absolutely love but it's
like the only thing that the artist is
done I totally get it walk out on a high
note
but for us consumers of music we want
more yeah yeah they're a few short story
writers who are novelists who are that
way to give that one work out there and
then it's done it's like yeah I've got
it I think there's definitely a rhythm
to to exciting it as with anything with
life there's like the the exhale on the
inhale and I talked to a few few friends
of mine that also produce music and they
sometimes have that feeling of like when
it's out and then you know maybe they
have personal goals or company goals
whatever it may be to like just go ahead
and just jump into the next thing
there's almost that moment of needing to
take another inhale first you know
before you before you get ready to
exhale again the work being the exhale
yeah however I also think you can go too
far and and hold your breath you know
yeah and so I what I try to do is give
myself you know a year to to in between
albums but but not more than two
constellation midnight wave just had a
year between them and it's like a time
to live your life - exactly and because
I I have run into that before I felt
like I clipped it too soon and and that
I I was maybe writing stories in lieu of
living them and and so now I try to make
sure that I give myself enough time to
inhale but also make sure that you know
I exhale again just keep that rhythm
going so it's easy - at least for me
it's easy to clip it too soon or to let
it go too long on either end and it
seems like it's an ever-shifting
equation of or not even equation but
just you know rhythm of creativity I
guess that's a beautiful line this is so
Sean that's a minimal maximum for you
there the show notes so we do these
things called minimal Maxim's we're like
we we they we Mandar on for really long
time and then sum it up with something
pithy there in our lightning round but
don't what he said don't write stories
in lieu of living them yeah and I've
only done that yeah well yeah and I
think so that book I was talking about
earlier Jonathan Franzen wrote a book
called freedom and I was right after his
really crazy popular book called the
corrections came out in 2001 and it took
him nine years to put out the neck
block and it was really eight years of
living one year of writing and he's I
realized I needed to go live for my life
for a while before I could create this
book I knew I wanted to create very
intentional and I think it's a tough
thing in America to and that the the
emphasis on work ethic is sometimes very
binary in that it's it's you know it's
to some degree it is just just showing
up and in doing the work but sometimes
part of my my work day is trying to get
inspired by going on a hike or going to
a museum or something and just trying to
ingest like trying to inhale or or just
simply making margin for relationships
or things like that and I sometimes have
to remind myself you know if I if I
don't do that then like this is actually
part of the work right and and and
redefining what work is and and if I do
that correctly I can keep it at an okay
pace but yeah finally that balance is
always an effort challenging thing have
you read daily rituals by Mason Currie I
haven't it's it's a great book but it's
I think 160 chapters and it's about the
daily rituals of different creative
people everyone from David Foster
Wallace yeah it's it's a phenomenal book
I mean it goes back to - all right doc
Thomas Jefferson and Benjamin Franklin
and Mozart and Beethoven and there are a
few there are a few commonalities
between a lot of them and one I noticed
was walking and and where they they
create something usually early in the
morning whatever early for them is for
some people like for me it's 3:30 in the
morning for other people it's 9:00 a.m.
like whenever that they get up and they
do it and but then they like there's a
period like a break where they go for a
walk and like sort of it's a I don't
know about you and I imagine it part of
it is auditory for you but I I write
auditorily and so I there's an outloud
--is-- sort of feel to a lot of the
words as of tumbling long sentences I
always get in trouble like WordPress is
like this thing it's like there are too
many words and your sentences it isn't
it but with clipart get or the was that
guys oh yeah
Clippy Orson yeah are you trying to
write a question and but I mean the
difference is like you can actually
track my sentence is grammatically and
syntactically so they work but there'll
be 40 words have any word sentences
sometimes and and it's just because
that's how we we we express ourselves
when we talk it's it's it's auditory but
when I noticed in in Mason Curry's book
daily rituals Sean I think you put a
link to that in the show notes it's it's
one of my favorite books because I
realized there were these patterns there
was stimulants like coffee like this
coffee I'm drinking here but the the
other one was walking and then the early
morning thing having some sort of
morning routine it could be different
for each people or each person but but
what I've realized is that that is part
of the process is walking away from it
can be the process yeah and you're right
there's this American work ethic it's
it's show up for 17 hours a day hustle
hustle hustle and there's a
congratulations for that - sounds like a
pride like oh man like I'm working you
know 80 hour weeks and it's almost like
a self congrat
what I was just say I was funny I think
about working there's 60 70 80 hour work
weeks
uh-huh and I look at that and I used to
pride myself on it and now I just look
back and I'm like wow Ryan you really
didn't know how to manage your time well
there was an it was an investment bank
it was some sort of Bank and I certainly
won't mention their name I don't wanna
get sued but I think it was an
investment bank where a guy died it was
working 72 hours straight there is a
name for it in Japan you work yourself
to death I forget what the name is but
there's there's a name for it you work
yourself to death and it's it is there's
a word and that's exactly what it means
that guy worked himself so hard he died
at a young age Wow it's crazy man yeah
and and the opposite of that there's
another another Japanese we're a key guy
are you familiar with this term you guys
yeah it means the basically that the
rough translation is the thing that gets
you out of bed in the morning nice okay
but and and that's the opposite right
because you do you do want to really put
in the effort but but studies show that
if you spend more than five hours
working on something and the time after
the five hours the diminished returns
like significantly in fat can yeah it
can negatively affect the create
you know and to your point about taking
the small breaks there's actually
studies that show like if you're
studying if you're writing if you're
working taking a 15 minute break like to
meditate to just sit there and let your
mind wander actually will help you be
more efficient helping you stay more
focused as the day moves on because
you're not constantly staying laser
focused on that right to where your
attention eventually you're like yeah
your attention gets exhausted and you
can't stay focused on them anymore it
gets more all over the place it's like
saying the same word over and over and
over if I say coffee table coffee table
coffee table if I keep saying it enough
it loses its total meeting right because
I'm so laser focused on it it just sort
of dissipates into the ether right I
think the other side of the dr.dre side
a thing where he's like he's got the
perfect multi trillion-dollar studio and
in every I mean it looks beautiful when
you see him behind that board you're
like that's what you need to make music
you know I can take it to space yeah
musk use of a giant Tesla studio and the
other side is did you see the movie once
with the Glen Hansard I did yeah so his
guitar has sort of become iconic be cool
in it yeah yeah have you seen Glen
Hansard guitar
we saw him live dude oh yeah we did he
still plays it live too so we saw him in
Cincinnati right downtown Cincinnati and
he came out and he's so good but he came
out off of the stage I know this is a
trope a lot of musicians do and but he
did it so beautifully it was big theater
2,000 people and he came into the middle
and like he had the whole audience fall
him out into the lobby Wow and he was
singing playing on that guitar with the
holes in it because you can tell he was
busking with that guitar verses so long
that it has this gigantic hole in it
that his actually in a weird way made
his sound unique because it obviously
changes the sound of the guitar right
working with the limitations yeah makes
you do things that that wouldn't
otherwise happen because you have to
kind like bend the lines and create new
sounds interesting and I think of other
great guitar players I think of
Jonny Lang who's also from the Fargo guy
or I think of John Mayer right yeah
probably have to be named John to be
good at guitar but uh thanks mom but
here's the thing with John Mayer Jonny
Lang there are both extremely talented
guitar players I can't think of their
guitar though I'm sure like if I was a
if if I was a guitar what's the
audiophile version of a guitar
enthusiast yeah if I'm a guitar
enthusiast like I'm sure I would know
what guitar is John Mayer plays whatever
but I don't notice it the same way I do
with Glen Hansard where I'm like oh like
there's a whole story the same way I can
look at one of your lines from
constellation I can I can look at his
guitar and there's a world in that it's
like Hemmingway podcast Sean's favorite
writer he the this the what is it the
six word short story little shoes or for
sale little shoes never worn yeah baby
shoes yeah and and just those six words
it there's a whole world in that and I
look at I look at Glen Hansard guitar
and it actually tells me a lot more
about him than if I look at that really
impressive dr. Dre 128 channel mixing
board that cost half a million dollars
like it looks really cool and impressive
but that guitar is equally impressive
not because of the instrument not
because of the artifact but because of
the story it tells what the it's
impressive to me because you can tell
that he put in the work there's evidence
of the work and it's not just the music
it's it's within the art makes me think
about I was in Vegas and I saw two shows
I saw Beatles love like Cirque du Soleil
cool and then I saw Penn & Teller and
Mariah was like which one did you like
the most and I'm like I love is the one
I liked the most but it was for the
wrong reasons it was because it's
because if you put like I love Beatles
music I really love circus acts love to
watch some good dancing so like you
insert all of this stimuli into a show
and it
just amazingly choreographed it's it's
such it's impossible for it not to be in
my opinion it's impossible for it not to
be a better show because there's so much
stimulus that they that they shove into
it yeah we're with Penn & Teller it was
it was it was great because for a
different reason it was great because it
was simple they would do these tricks
that you know were seemingly simple but
then they'd you know do these amazing
things but there was also this aspect of
like they sell this little metal bill of
rights and they had this whole trick
where they go through the metal detector
and it goes off and he's like oh yeah
here um I have this uh sorry it's my
Bill of Rights that are in my pocket and
then like you know he hands them to the
TSA agent here take my pill take take my
rights it's it's very clever it's very
well done that is great but uh but yeah
it's it's amazing that you could take do
not have that that seems like something
you would he hasn't got it yet that was
my almost bottom one my just in case
rule so I'm getting it but he needs it I
feel like it's this is essential for
yeah so he can pontificate in front of
the TSA I guess I guess really it's it's
interesting how you can take you can
take a multi-million dollar production
or you can take a very simple production
yes and either can be amazing I mean you
can look at Avatar and you can look at
Blair which both of them did amazing in
the box office both of them were smash
hit movies yeah I think that really
speaks to you know to to what is his
name Adam yeah I think that speaks to
Adams Adams question about how can he
keep less stuff is is really realized
that it's not the stuff that's going to
make him a good climber yes it's it's
him that's going to make him a good
climber yeah and some of those things
can augment the experience like Paul you
be way worse off you didn't own a guitar
sure sure I mean you could borrow one or
whatever like I did this experiment for
a year where I didn't I thought it'd be
the easiest thing because we're all
minimalist right so I was like I'm not
gonna buy anything for a year
other than food and like hygiene
products like I need soap but uh no new
material items and it was going pretty
well it was difficult at first but then
my I spilled tea all over my laptop and
and like I write for a living and and so
like I'm like well no I'm gonna he's
like no no worries Otis borrow Ryan's
Dell laptop or I'd go to the library and
you come over to my house and like use
my computer
I'd have yellow legal pad like just
filled up with essays that I had written
and I come over on my hey can I start
writing this out on your computer cuz
the library kicked me out they only gave
me two hours on the computer and and
eventually I realized you know what this
is actually this is the wrong kind of
deprivation I believe it's good to
temporarily deprive ourselves to to
breed that creativity but if I were to
take away all your instruments and and
your ability to record that's not gonna
help you it's gonna hurt you you're
gonna well you end up being a you seem
like a crazy person just be out here
Hollywood Boulevard like singing to
people and and so it's gonna be less
productive but buying 50 guitars for you
well although each of them might be
really cool like oh that's a 57 Gibson
and you're like oh man it's beautiful I
agree it's beautiful but but at some
point it actually gets in the way of
creating the thing you want you set out
to create too many choices and that's
yes especially with digital recording
now which I mean I I I use in am a fan
of but it's there can be an infinity of
you can always tinker and it can be so
hard to finish and what I what I've
learned and because I do a lot of a lot
of production with with Canyon City a
lot of that stuff is just me alone in a
room you know messing with things and
what I've learned is to let go at like
90 to 95% that there's kind of like a
point where like what you want is you
know like here's this isn't an a-plus
but it is it is an a very strong egg
exactly and that's that con where has to
be because there's look there's like
that line of a hundred percent and you
you work and you work and it kind of
goes up exponentially and you get to
maybe like eighty nine ninety percent
and then there's a point where maybe
this is just the time and solitude that
I spend doing it but there's a point
where then it starts to go down to
eighty nine and eighty seven and so it's
like I'm stopping at ninety and saying
like I in my head I know there's a
better version
you gotta know when to stuck there's a
next ya there's there's the next thing
to say after this album and so I'm gonna
have to let this be a 90 and and yeah
and go to the next thing to that point
man when I think about our documentary I
was telling Josh after we taped that
special I ever have walked away there
were very few times I've walked away
from an event and felt like man that was
I could not have done any better
yeah there's I mean literally I can
think of maybe twice I walked away and I
went home and I was like man Ryan
there's nothing else that you or Josh
could have done to make that event
better and every ninety eight percent of
everything else I have the feeling of
this wanting of wanting to do better but
in the same token to your point I think
that that's what helps Josh and I to
improve it is it is walking away and
saying oh [ __ ] man we really should have
done X Y & Z and then the next time like
we make sure to do X Y yeah it's all
part of the the growth and then you're
what what is a hundred percent starts to
elevate and you know what what you
considered ninety percent last year is
is actually like a hundred and ten you
know oh yeah like if we were to grade
ourselves on minimalism live a
meaningful life yeah in fact we had to
rewrite the book in 2015 loose until I
get it back up to standard so that was
our first book came out in 2011 and it
was like by 2015 it was like okay like
this was so good the principles are
really sound in this but it needs it
needs to be reworked and so we had Sean
on board Sean is the best editor that we
know he's amazing with that and so
having this clean pair of eyes to help
bring it back up to what our current
standard was but at some point you even
then you have to walk away from and say
that's the best I could do given the
resources I had at the moment but
realizing it's going to change over time
and so I think if Adam wants to become a
better climber then it's the focus on
the climbing and then the question is
what tools are necessary for you to
create or to climb or what materials do
you need to do that to the best of your
ability and maybe that means taking away
some of the materials temporarily now I
has Adams the only person I hesitate to
not say that too because I don't want
you to die Adam so be safe no matter
what you can get hurt even with all of
the the best tools in the world you can
still hurt yourself and so be careful
but but I think sometimes take
that away when I lost my computer here
or when I lost access to using the
Internet didn't use internet at home for
five years I think I had a certain kind
of new creative spark in my life that
wasn't there
previously and and I think that
sometimes we're moving the excess the
superfluous and we don't know what super
flows could be we tell ourselves all the
stories we can just the word you used
earlier was justify I can justify
bringing anything into my life you know
if you give me a day to write about
write about it I could do anything to
justify any purchase imaginable right
but that yeah there's plenty because I
would just say people all the time right
in like well what about this situation
what about that situation and I just
want to say if anyone needs
justification yes you can find any
justification for anything yeah
absolutely man I mean you you when when
when I look at the things that I bring
into my life quite often I've I've given
myself permission and really the only
justification you don't need to justify
these purchases to anyone else and I
think that's quite often what people
were saying is like how do I justify
this to my my partner my spouse my my
mother my whoever yeah no no use these
you need to be able to justify to
yourself absolutely that's the hardest
part if you're able to be honest with
yourself because you you might go to
give out this advice like yeah yeah I
shouldn't know him too much whatever but
taking your own advice that's the
hardest pill to swallow right and so the
last thing I'll say for Adam here is
here's the thing you're asking this
question about access equipment and if
you are asking the question then yeah
you might have too much but it's up to
you to determine what is enough because
your version of enough is going to look
different from my version of enough
enough climbing equipment for me is zero
I don't do any climbing I'll do some
bouldering occasionally I'll show up to
a little place and you know they have
whatever equipment I need to rent there
but I don't need to own any that
equipment myself so it's gonna be
different for everyone
so what is your version of enough and
once you determine what that version is
realize it changes over time what is
enough today maybe too much tomorrow it
might be too little too
yeah and so you have to be willing to
let go of what you find value in today
as as the time progresses yeah what's
that line from one of your songs you
said man I'm thinking of telling my idea
we're living today off of tomorrow's
broke clocks it's so good I don't I
don't even know exactly what tomorrow's
broke clock yeah yeah it's it's part of
it like a it's a course that changes
throughout this song I don't even want
to know what he meant by that I just I
want to make my own interpretation
exactly I'm good man yeah I'm not trying
to get your interpretation in fact I
just want to leave it out there we are
living today off tomorrow's broke clocks
and and in the wait the way that I
interpreted that when I first heard that
again it's one of those pause moment so
I'm like oh yeah I don't know what that
means exactly but but then I was
thinking about I'm like it's it's about
living in the moment and for me it's
like what is right right now and then
obviously tomorrow is is going to change
right and you're welcome to dive in if
you want say Josh you're full of crap or
what else that's a beautiful translation
as for my meals it was just the the
fleeting moment and yes and and but but
like recognizing that that scarcity also
makes it special to and and kind of adds
value to it because it's a real scarcity
it's not I mean the problem is we
manufacture scarcity in our culture we
see 5000 advertisements a day and
they're all trying to act now so
supplies are limited only so we're
recording that is NOAA recording an
episode on President's Day and it's like
Presidents Day we even commodified
Presidents Day we're gonna get me for
President's Day Josh obviously a
mattress cuz they're honest and I mean
that's the thing you see Presidents Day
sales act act now or you'll see like
Presidents Day week sale and you're like
wait a minute that is a week sale yurt
in beforebefore Canyon City before was
my full-time gig I worked in a retail
store and sometimes that was a tactic
that they would had like they would they
would take a few things off of the shelf
and put them in the back thing so that
it looked like they're about to run out
even if they had you know I
plenty of them in the background just to
create that sense of urgency of like
this is full scarcity of good talking
about is a different kind of scarcity
where we're we're all gonna die right
yeah and it's very true scarcity you
have a new song out it's called it's
called shadows yeah that's right and
it's a single and I tend to hate singles
I'm the album guy man and I'm yeah I'm
part of a dying breed right and it's a
good breed though that's a good one and
I get it so it's that's a manufactured
thing too because a hundred years ago
albums weren't really a thing it was you
know was well even a hundred years ago
there's very little recorded music play
I hate dude I hate it when like you hear
a song on the radio you go buy this CD
and like that's the only good song on a
CD
yeah and you you spend what CDs used to
be $17.99 grief we'd go over to the CD
connection remember down in the eighth
grade I remember thinking man if I could
just somehow start a business where and
I was thinking this with cassette tapes
where people come in they could choose
any song they want and then they can
make their own mixed cassette tape
Paul's looking like guys what is a
cassette no right Oh 1998 I think I'm
after hit the scene they totally ripped
my idea off Josh good so they should
suit you not Napster exactly
they Winklevoss to you okay
cuz that's are coming back though they
are yeah like it's vinyls having like
some of their biggest years in a while
yeah because it's yeah it's it's a funny
thing because I mean initially I mean
obviously albums were just you know a
product of the medium and and now I
think it's more of a creative choice
like it's everything lives in playlists
and and and sort of and just kind of
like momentary things but I still think
it's important at least for as an artist
to create with a album mindset and a lot
of time because it creates it allows for
there to be I don't know allows for
every song to not have to be to totally
capitulate everything that you want to
say you can sort of have a longer
dialogue throughout
thing and then I do that with the
understanding that you know it's
probably not going to be digested in
that form it may not in my most most
people but I think one of the the silver
linings is in the streaming world is
that it does force people to make good
songs throughout the hooks I think that
for a while when like you have to buy
the CD to get the single you liked there
was almost like a laziness in the music
industry of like oh like we can do like
seven fillers and three singles you know
and it was for now it's like if it's not
a good song people just won't listen and
you know they don't have to because it's
it's all just kind of and there's I
think there's there it's an interesting
ying and yang to the the new scenario
well I also think that the opposite was
also true like someone like you would go
and create seven songs that you really
loved and or eight songs and then the
record we would force you to make two
songs that you hated so that I can sell
the album better and then what would
happen is people who love the the single
that you don't love they would do it
Ryan did and he'd show up and he'd like
listen to anyway I like that song but
now I've got these eight other songs
that don't resonate with me and I think
that's the nice thing about about the
world that we're in now I love the fact
that we can stream music right I mean I
have an infinite library in my pocket
right now I used to have like a 2000 CD
collection all I mean I've got book and
all that stuff no mine was alphabetized
on the wall nice yeah when we would go
buy albums he would get the cassette and
the CD that's right because my mom's car
had a tape player right and and so yeah
I I didn't have a really good way to
yeah bit in the cassette yeah and now
it's like right there on my phone and
it's beautiful and I agree with you like
now if a song really resonates doesn't
have to be the single whatever that even
means now it can be like this great
thing if someone puts it on a Spotify
puts it on there they're you know new
music Friday playlist and all of a
sudden it's like who's this Canyon City
right and I'm sure that's how I heard
about you was on Apple music someone had
you on some sort of playlist or new
artist or whatever it was and it showed
up there right and that's the beauty of
that I it would have been much harder to
find you
a record store because you you're like
checking for album covers
I like this album cover enough to spend
$15 on this and just guess on it yeah
yeah and sometimes I guess and it would
sometimes work out but usually not and
was a lot of wasted money and now I can
now I can listen to it the money side of
things which we'll get into in a moment
is certainly different because now
artists are really trying to find a way
it's it's opened up this whole new
avenue for you to develop an audience
but then it's like how do I make a
living off of this - which is an
important aspect I think we got a money
question a little bit later on right
Emily well for Adam I'm sure we answered
your question flawlessly and you've got
everything you need to know now about
moving forward with your sports sports
sports equipment we we're gonna say your
copy of our book essential it's an essay
collection with a 150 different essays
in there and the reason I'm gonna send
you a copy of that Adam is there's an
entire chapter in there on stuff and
collections and hoarding and and there's
also a chapter about minimalism and in
sort of the process of letting go so
Sean if you could reach out to Adam and
get him a audio book copy if you like
our podcast you're probably like the
audiobook of that it's over six hours
long I think there's close to six hours
long so a lot of of good tips and tricks
from the minimalist in that book it's
called essential essays by the
minimalist or if he doesn't want the
audiobook you're welcome to sit in the
physical book or the the e-book as well
our next question is from Gabriella in
Oakland I am an artist and I'm a project
manager for work and what I love to do
is I hand paint textiles I have this
work where I'm in my house
and I've been really interested in the
more them for quite a long time but I've
never found any information on when you
have something that you do that you love
that requires a lot of fame like sewing
has like a thousand tools and so I'm
wondering if you guys can talk about
that because there are a lot of people
who have work rooms I don't have the
luxury of having a laptop and that's it
and I feel like a lot of these things
that I read and tips and all this stuff
it's geared towards that it's like oh
let's have the laptop
but nothing else on the desk but I don't
it doesn't work that way and so that's
I'm looking for like some practical
application and like how do you do that
well I have some bad news you're gonna
have to get rid of everything except
your laptop you know it's funny I heard
this and I know she paints textiles but
I thought you know what like there there
are a lot of artists who have only a
laptop now I understand she paid textile
so this is a different type of artists
skill set but it is possible
have you heard of Microsoft Paint dude
I've seen some amazing things done it's
really amazing I mean I think about like
Collins work dude Colin is an artist
yeah totally he doesn't have a designer
Yeah right exactly doesn't full stuff
but but in this in this situation in
Gabriella's situation she does have a
room full of stuff because that is the
type of art that she chooses to do which
is great I'm so happy that she has found
something that she loves a hobby that
she likes to do gabriella
congratulations um
I think with Gabriela I think this will
hold true with Adam as well earlier is
dude we we have to create limitations
for ourselves we really have to enforce
these things in our lives that are going
to help us breed the creation that we
desire with Gabriela if she holds on to
every single textile that she comes
across if she buys every single you know
oil paint that acrylic paint whatever
paint she uses that she comes across
well then she's just gonna have a bunch
of paint and textiles it'd be like if
you bought every instrument that piques
your interest every every guitar pick
that you you stumbled across you know I
gotta have this one it's slightly but
but I'll just say this you have a
workroom in your house you said I'll
just say there's nothing inherently
wrong with having a workroom
if you need I mean Ryan and I are in
this workroom that we call our studio
right now that stuff in here we've got
three microphones that's right we got
three mic stands I've got a podcast Sean
took the words out of my
and of course two laptops that's right
and of course two laptops on a white
table that is true here's the thing the
question that I then ask is what is
necessary for me to create you said you
have a thousand tools that are be and
are those thousand tools being used if
so how frequently right my guess is if
you have a thousand tools like literally
if you were I'm not telling you to count
them or anything but if you have a
thousand tools how frequently can you
use them you know there are people with
a thousand guitars you know collection
with a thousand guitars and many of them
haven't been played for many years yeah
it's kind of sad it's like that
potential for this beautiful thing to to
wring out and and and there are so many
musicians who would actually find value
in that thing right and so for Gabriella
do they stress you out the the having a
thought I mean the reason you're calling
in it to me is either a you're asking
for permission to keep itself and if
that's the case permission granted you
don't need our permission Gabriel to
keep it but or be your calling because
maybe there's a little bit of stress you
say okay I need some of the stuff and
maybe I have too much I haven't reached
today to taunt with the the amount of
stuff I need in order to to create to
the best of my ability and so if they
stress you out
could someone else get value from them
with someone else benefit from having
some of those thousand tools for the
person who has a thousand guitars maybe
you don't need a thousand maybe you need
a hundred yeah and could nine hundred
other people get value from from those
guitars right dude I think that speaks
right into her having to create some of
these limitations for herself so Paul
I'm interested man I'm sure that you
will come across an instrument and a
Cajon and you will say or is it good
Joan come on Cajon okay all right you
come across in your life gift situation
box you sit on and play like a drum
right you could you might look at
something like that and think man that
would be really fun to play and I could
probably make some really awesome music
with that and then you start to think
about the cool things you could do with
that Cajon it's instantly gonna make you
want to buy it but I know you don't do
that so
what kind of limitations do you have on
yourself it helps you to prevent its
finalists and it's it's certainly fine
like so there have been times when like
with a current guitar that I I tore with
and I recorded there were times when I
get that and there's like almost an
inspiration that came with that new
instrument mm-hmm
however and so there's been times with
when the new tools expanded the horizon
a bit yeah but I I would say there
there's also as many decisions that are
made for me before I step into the
studio to create the song the more time
I'm gonna spend singing creating and
really trying to decorate the music so I
tried to create as little of a technical
barrier in between in between basically
the what's in my head and what ends up
in the in the the song and so I I just
got a few new microphones that are
really helping me get a sound that I
more like and spend a little less time
playing with eq's and that kind of stuff
but with my old microphone I have a
buddy that's just now trying to get into
music and so I was like well hey man
like I like I'm probably not gonna use
$150 microphone anymore because I just
got this this nicer one like do you do
you want to use that and and so it's
it's in some cases the new thing adds a
coloration that does expand the
territory for me but if I'm like okay
well that's now where I live and the
thing that was maybe before that or or
that I moved on from I can kind of let
go that as opposed to I know you guys
would say like the Justin taste thing as
opposed to saying like you know I'm
gonna have this keep it around just just
in case and so I do try to and that
would be so much to do like I've got
this old microphone yeah it's it's
probably this big I'm holding like my
hands out right now in front of Paul you
could probably stick that in a drawer
and I think about it yeah and you might
there might be a sound on that there
might be there isn't like right away you
don't look at that microphone I think oh
there's a sound on there that only that
microphone can provide but certainly
there might be yeah just in case and I
think oh god I was so with art too
sometimes there's installed yeah I mean
like that the microphone that I gave
away was the microphone that I used on
all of midnight waves and it's like
there it's on a certain sense there
there could be a sense of you know like
oh well this is what I this well you
know it's it's the value of that record
is not in the microphone that I used on
it it's in the songs and the
the people that gave it life that by
listening to it and stuff and so I think
that's also another element of
difficulty is is like the emotional
especially when you're doing artistic
stuff with it another yeah I think it's
cool that you gave it to your friend man
it's like you as the artist have made
some beautiful works with this piece of
equipment and now you're like kind of
passing the baton on to your friend for
them to make some beautiful work and it
otherwise would just be sitting in you
know a mic Locker and not doing anything
so I'd much rather it be be doing that
but myself is not sacred it's what it
was able to accomplish for you at your
time and it could continue to serve a
purpose for you but you've decided that
there's a different direction you want
to go that makes more sense for what
you're trying to create in the future
I'm reminded of there's a guy named Pete
Rollins I'm not sure if you're familiar
with him he's a evangelical a new
podcast right now called the
fundamentalists but it's sort of it's
him and a comedian he's on Rob Bell's
podcasts all the time he's from Belfast
and he is sort of known as so Rob Bell
has this documentary coming out called
The Heretic while Pete Rollins wrote a
book called the Orthodox heretic and and
so he's known for doing sort of
unorthodox things in the world of
Orthodox Christianity and this this
story is applicable whether whatever
your religious beliefs are Ryan and I
have different spiritual beliefs but he
he was known for a while he would go
into lay a couple mega churches like the
big sort of churches in the south and I
think about this for a second he go into
a church a big mega church and he'd rip
a Bible up on the stage now isn't it
when he wasn't trying to impose people
off or like trying to he wasn't trying
to say like he's certain look what his
piece of crap he was he was certainly
trying to piss people off because he
wasn't he wasn't trying to piss them off
he was trying trying to be tantalizing
and he was trying to to to get people to
think he was yeah he was trying to he
was trying to get reaction whether that
was being pissed off or whether that was
being tantalize or whatever it was he
wanted to take you to a certain emotion
right and then and then help you unpack
that emotion yeah and help you
understand that hey
this is this artifact it's just it's
just a ball of clay the the power for
him was in the words and the parables
and the stories that were in that book
right and I often tell people that with
our own books I'm like hey once you like
give value from this thing like please
pass it on to someone a library yeah
give it to a friend family member throw
it at an enemy do something that because
the the power is in the words is not
that does no good just sing on your
bookshelf collecting dust and and I
think that's what he was trying to
communicate and then of course like
there was people who got really who did
get pissed off and of course and they
went to their the lead pastor of the
church and in Twitter I'm sure they
probably did we didn't episode it was
episode of a fifty five of our podcast
called critics and where Ryan and I read
mean tweets about our documentary it's
one of my favorite episodes we've ever
remember I saw you guys in Nashville I
think it was either there or in DC I
think wasn't Nashville you referenced
one of those about like Ryan hugging
every brave hugging everyone yeah you
know I brought up Twitter because I
brought up Twitter because Shawn and I
went and saw a podcast on and I and
Mariah we went and saw Tim Allen last
night you know Taylor yeah and the whole
time he's like please don't go to
Twitter after this please don't go
tweeting this these are jokes that's
other thing people don't realize with
comedians like they give away their
whole sets or whatever and just come up
with new material
no they worked for years on that
material and and now you're just giving
it away
it ruins runs a joke for other people
play here's the thing people will go to
the the lead pastor of that church and
and they're like complaining like I just
it was not right what he did to that
book and it's a sacred book and so the
pastor trying to be very nice and he was
like all right I understand where you're
coming from and he took a cd-rom of the
Bible off the shelf and broke it into
and he goes do that make you feel bad
they're like no that's different though
and he's like no it's not different it's
the same thing it's just a vehicle right
and I think that's what we get caught up
and these tools the Gabriella
talking about these are our vehicles to
get you to create what you want to
create it's part of the the creating
experience but sometimes we have a
thousand tools sometimes those tools get
in the way of the creation they stifle
the creativity going back to the dr.dre
analogy or think of any other analogy
when when you're focusing solely on the
tools you get you get lost in in the
acquisition process and not in the
process of creating we get consumed by
consumption I'd rather be consumed by
the the creating side and then you can
use whatever tools are necessary to
create whatever you want to create yeah
get real I mean think about think about
this when I was going through all my
stuff with the packing party Josh had to
talk me into basically getting rid of
anything that I hadn't used for the last
year and and if I was honest with myself
probably wasn't going to use within the
next year that that is a rule that I
actually have shortened that now now
it's you know the 9090 rule I can do
most of my things I can I can look at it
in a ninety-day sense instead of a
365-day sense but but you know I really
want to encourage Gabriela here to put
those rules in place because here's the
beautiful thing let's say she literally
limits herself literally limits herself
to a white table and a laptop mm-hmm
she's gonna sit there and she's gonna
discover one of two things she's gonna
discover like oh wow I can I can't
create with this laptop and in some
weird way I don't know she could paint a
textile with a laptop I understand
that's impossible just bear with me yeah
so she might realize like oh wow I can
actually create with a laptop or she
will look at it and say it is impossible
for me to paint a textile with this
laptop I absolutely I need a textile and
I need a paintbrush yeah you sir asked
some good questions what do I need
exactly what are the fundamentals what
are one of the essentials they're gonna
help me create and then you build from
that place instead of trying to build
from the place of overabundance of a
hoard of stuff that may be getting in in
the way of the creating yeah I think
there's a confidence and a freedom in
that too and when when you when you
realize that the creation is is really
fairly portable within you and
you know it's something that you know
you don't write that down Shawn
creativity is portable ah and there's a
John Mayer song what is it he said pack
me up take me out on portable yeah yeah
yeah and it's I think there's like a
empowerment in that and it's like it's
like yeah these are the tools to get it
out but like it's that they aren't what
makes this special or what makes what
I'm doing special is not you know this
this crazy piece of gear that I'm using
or something like that it's it's you
know the thing that is kind of being
born out of out of this person and it's
fun thing everybody knows I don't know
what this means but like going back to
the circus away versus the Penn & Teller
show I am way more impressed with Penn &
Teller way more impressed with Penn &
Teller's on the Cirque du Soleil
I enjoyed the Cirque du Soleil more
because again all the stimuli and it's I
just have never seen anything like it
but but going back to that Penn & Teller
show I would much rather go back and see
that Penn & Teller show again then the
Cirque du Soleil yeah because because of
the simplicity and because of how
they're they're able to be two dudes
like I hope one day we can be as awesome
as Penn & Teller Josh well like I
stopped talking right now done have you
seen Chris D'Elia you know I could never
stop talking he posted this thing
there's this I think it's called like
the hush or something and just contrast
you put on your face you look like Bain
but if you want to like have a private
phone call you can have like a phone
booth around your mouth I was thinking
about getting one of those for you just
for wear around try this out I was
thinking there's two other things you
mentioned what you're getting me for
President's Day 30% off I had to act now
the the 9090 rule you mentioned have I
use this in the last 90 days am I gonna
use it in the next 90 days and for for
Gabrielle and her tools maybe it's last
year have I used this last year or am I
going to meet it's two years it could be
whatever and start somewhere just have
some rule in place that you can live by
and of course you might want to make an
exception but try not to make an
exception if you setup the rule then
to make an exception I always gives this
advice and start with a year and then
pare down yes and I say start paring
down and then scale up because going
back to that example of if she if she
removes everything yeah this is a very
still cool experiment yeah don't just
throw everything out you can box it up
you can box it off if you're packing
party on your tools but but anyone
facing this type of situation is it
literally limit yourself to nothing and
then start bringing stuff in as you need
it it's so much better man yeah what you
need yeah wish I would have done that
wait I wish I would have done the 9090
way sooner and so I the only thing that
I think about is the just in case rule
we often think about these things we
hold on to a thousand tools right
because I'm gonna hold on to that just
in case I need it someday just in case I
want to go back and record on that
microphone just in case I'm gonna use
that paintbrush or whatever even though
it's past the the 9090 rule or the
one-year rule or whatever but they're
not really they're not items we ever use
it and I think the nice thing about
starting with a blank slate is you'll
realize you don't need most you're not
gonna bring most of the things back in
right but there are some things that
will fall outside you ninety-nine rule
they're just for winners yeah my
snowboard like I'm not gonna go well I
don't know what the 9090 rule Falls but
my snowboard we're not falling in there
and pretty probably not but it's it's
you also know you're going to use it at
some point right you're certain about it
is it just for one absolutely yeah and
in you continue reevaluate then if one
day you decide hey I'm not snowboarding
at all anymore but then I think we have
to admit that I tend to reevaluate that
every single like every single time the
first day of the season that I go on
that first like long windy lift hmm I
always contemplate am I gonna do this
next year but then as soon as I start
going down the hill I'm like oh yeah
yeah definitely
yeah oh yeah I'm gonna keep doing this
yeah and you know it we have to be
willing to let go of part sometimes that
becomes part of our identity right one
thing I let go of pretty recently I
think it's all until very recently I
consider myself primarily a fiction
writer and that that's what I did
throughout my 20s I enjoyed doing that
even when I was in the corporate world
and that this was you know I didn't have
plans for the whole minimalism thing it
was a great that it worked out that this
way but I thought maybe this would be a
cool springboard maybe to to launch that
that fiction writing career and well I
still enjoy
that side of things I no longer think of
myself as a fiction writer I had to let
go of that because it wasn't something I
do regularly anymore I write still and I
write frequently I write almost every
day but I don't consider myself fixture
because it's not doing that anymore I
don't let go of that sort of label right
and so I think when we let go of that
label it frees up the the creativity as
well and it's like okay I'm not in that
box anymore I'm able to create and so
Paul with your last album like I know
that like there might be some nostalgia
or that you needed this particular piece
of equipment to or this guitar was just
right to record that album but as a as a
listener of a consumer of the music I
think I don't really care about like
what guitar you used right Tom Petty had
a great quote in this documentary says
nobody cares how records are made they
carry other sound yes and and that's
really I think the it's also just that
you know what you're just saying about
like letting go of certain labels or
certain thing it's also the permission
to to move forward to like I always
loved I haven't moved in a while but I
always loved the feeling after a move
when everything is colics at that point
I've sort of looked at everything and
you know decide whether or not I and
it's almost like there's there's it's
like a spring season of life right after
move because you have permission to like
become a new person sort of reach it you
know reevaluate just your your days
structure and all that stuff and the I
think reevaluate the box that's been
moving with you yeah you have an open
yeah yeah I think with artistic tools it
does the same thing where if I'm you
know if I'm because inevitably you're
gonna be a different person with every
project and and and so it's gonna grow
and it's gonna change and I think if the
stuff that you're using also reflects
that and says I I couldn't recreate
Elden number one if I wanted to it would
just be a knockoff you know and so like
let's let's abandon even trying to do
that and let's let it go and move
forward and see what what you know
what's new that the things that's a
scarier thing though it's always scarier
to go for the uncertain future than to
try to sort of knock off the certain
past yeah well then that that that
repetition can also breathe some sort of
despair as well we're going to feel like
we're not growing if there are some
artists that are able to do it somehow I
keep making the same album over and over
and oh
and quite often they sound good but at
some point you're like like don't you
wanna don't wanna move beyond that
there's an artist I think of Matt Carney
who lives in Nashville and he is on tour
right now with Andrew Bell oh yeah and
they I mean I think of all that both of
those guys actually like their sound has
evolved album album especially Matt
Carney like you could tell there's sort
of this this period I he did the
singer-songwriter thing mixed with like
the sort of hip-hop thing and then he
his second album was more like it was
geared toward making live music and and
and and each album has a distinct sound
that is so different from the previous
album but it's still very Matt Carney
it's just the evolution of Matt Carney
from being 25 to being a 39 or however
ahold he is now and you realize like
he's able to grow with that still be
himself but in order to do that he had
to leave the past behind he had to leave
that binds okay that was a moment and as
imperfect as it was I have to move on
from that the other thing I think about
when you're talking about the tools what
tools were using Jack Johnson is a great
example because he he talks about how
like he was a film director and a
musician and I wasn't very good at
filmed her I think because I would just
like start throwing the cameras in the
bag and the lenses I was I was beating
him up I wasn't paying attention
and people asked him like what guitar he
used and he's like I mean look at my eye
he's out of someone just gave me this
one and I really like it now but he's
like I don't really get caught up in and
the the instrument or the tool like they
are tools but I don't want to fetishize
the the instrument I want to just play
it and enjoy the experience of getting
it out there yeah heaven Jimi Hendrix's
guitar does not make you Jimmy and ah
that's I wish that's pithy I wish a lot
of musicians in Nashville knew that
because it's it's a there's definitely a
culture of like gear maybe almost in
instead of creating with it you know
like like it's in especially the studios
it's just you know yeah like a showcase
room and that kind of stuff yeah it's
easy to get caught up in man I mean it
would excite me if someone if someone
like you know handed me this used to
belong to Jimi Hendrix I mean certainly
there's going to be some kind of
nostalgia there but
there's what I understand the like I'm
gonna have to work really really hard to
make that guitar sound if I would ever
even be able to make that guitar sound
the same way that he did right right we
had a on that song on this tour we did a
really brief stint in the UK and we kind
of had had ourselves a moment of just
tourism and vanity where we booked a day
in a be road studios which was totally
like I I knew that I could actually like
my because of my workflow and because of
the way to have my setup in my home I
knew that I actually probably could make
a better session like a more productive
day at home but it was just out of you
know Reverend said that the place yeah
but I still don't reel-to-reel or they
they can we we didn't know we did we
just did because I was going to take the
files home and edit them and all that
good stuff but it was definitely a it
was it was a interesting thing because
on one side there ad we did for a day
because there was like you know here's
where you know these sort of the music
happened and and were some of these guys
ate and you know played and that kind of
stuff but I remember about halfway
through the day thinking like I I think
I can actually do like a little bit
better job at home you know like and I
got and then we also uh my photography
er Thomas and I we we had like when we
were setting up just you know we had a
great engineer but I I'm sure he was mad
at us because we were just like banging
out let it be on the piano with like no
reference whatsoever karaoke style yeah
it's it's a you know it was certainly a
moment of like we're in the space that
does not make us the Beatles you know
interesting
well it's funny cuz that space it wasn't
even that space and until the Beatles
were there yeah like they are the ones
who made it that space yeah if I handed
you Joe Rogan's microphone we're not
gonna be able to have a conversation
like you're Rogen I think we literally
use the same microphones yeah but not
it's not his microphone what if we could
get his microphone we'd be just as
awesome you're probably not anyway
Gabriella there's an entire chapter on
creativity and passion in our book
minimalism live a meaningful life and
I'd love to give you a copy of that so
Sean if you could reach out to her and
give her an audio book copy or the book
book or the e-book I'd really appreciate
it and let's let's move on Oh before we
move on Ryan we love
here what you all have to say if you're
listening to this at home or in your car
or on a treadmill or if you had to log
on to the Internet what sorry that was
like an inside joke reference to like a
couple episodes ago if you're out there
just free climbing listening to this
podcast wheel on yeah please do please
press pause and go get some gear one of
the rare times you hear us say that yeah
like a parachute alright we'd love to
hear what you have to say so people
comment or tip about hobbies or anything
that we've talked about today or advice
for any of our callers today leave a
voicemail for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine you can also
email a voice memo right from your phone
to podcast at the minimalists comm will
air our favorite comments and tips on a
future episode Ryan what time is it it's
time for our lightning round where we
answer questions from social media Josh
I got to be honest man I'm really
looking forward to these tips and tricks
because I get asked a lot about how
artists
yeah what artists specifically should
you in fact in my notes of essay ideas
one is artists supplies so if there are
any artists out there I really really
look forward to hearing what you have to
say or if we just get Paul to write one
line that's gonna sum up everything
that's right we can put in a song
somewhere yeah but I definitely go ahead
and call us or send us a voice memo from
your phone would love to get your tips
and tricks on a future episode it's time
for the lightning round we're on Twitter
Facebook and Instagram at the
minimalists during the lightning round
this is where Ryan and I do our best to
each answer a question or a couple
questions here with just a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we also put the text to these
minimal Maxim's in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you'd like and now you
can find all of our quotes in one place
it's minimal Maxim's calm all right our
first lightning round question is from
Lucy Lucy writes in is it still a hobby
if you make money from it so I think
that really echoes what you were talking
about earlier Paul you don't have to
have a pithy answer right away we can
a little bit and we'll get there
eventually my I borrowed the short short
pithy answer but this minute will Maxim
hear from Drake and then I added to it
if the outcome is income it's not a javi
and I really I really think that quite
often we get so caught up in money so I
have this little essay here from Derek
Siver's he is a and you're gonna love
this book it's so he's one of my
favorite writers it's called the mindset
of marketing your music which I don't
love the title and I'm gonna have to
talk to him about the the title of it so
you knew Derek severs we've been
emailing back and forth but he he he's
super talented as a writer he's a great
book called anything you want and but he
has this book that's sort of online I
don't know if he's gonna he put it out a
while ago he's rewriting the whole thing
but this chapter is about money and so
he is he's really short pithy chapters
that I almost like Zinn like and in
their in their brevity
it's called shed your money taboos and
by the way I think this book is more
like a it says it's it's for marketing
your music but I think it's the mindset
of marketing for creative people really
cuz it's it goes way beyond the mere
hitting yourself
yeah yeah especially if you're a
creative person or you're trying to
create so is that your new title for it
yeah I gotta find something good cuz he
has the best title can you legally do
that just change someone else's title
yeah I've done it already I changed your
title to CEO oh nice finally got that
c-level congratulations
so it turns out this is happiness I just
walked out right coming back alright so
this is called shed your money taboos
everyone has weird mental associations
with money they think the only way to
make money is to take it away from
others they think that charging for your
art means it was insincere and only for
profit but after being around the music
business for 20 years and knowing
thousands of musicians I've learned this
the unhappiest musicians I've met are
the ones who avoided the subject of
money and now are desperately broke or
need a draining day job
may sound cool to say money doesn't
matter to say don't worry about it in
the negotiation moment but it leads to a
really hard life then ultimately your
music suffers because you can't give it
the time it needs and you haven't found
an audience that values it the happiest
musicians I know are the ones who
developed a valuable aspect of their
skill and confidently charge a high
price there's a deep satisfaction when
you know how valuable you are and the
world agrees then it reinforces itself
as you can focus on being the best
artist you can be since you've found an
audience that rewards you well for it so
never underestimate the importance of
making money
let go of any taboos you have about it
money is nothing more than a neutral
exchange of value if people give you
money it's proof that you're giving them
something valuable in return so by
focusing on making money with your music
you're making sure it's valuable to
others not only to you I think it's so
important because here's the thing that
might little pithy answer was like if
the outcome is income then it's not a
hobby but that's that's okay here's the
thing I don't want the primary driver of
what I do what I create to be money but
I think it's a part of the process is
what their exhibit is saying here like
because otherwise you are if it's if
it's just part of the process but it's
not leading then you're being honest
about you need to earn a living from
that thing and that's okay but if it
becomes the primary driver then we start
to sacrifice you were you were hinting
at that earlier like I had to get rid of
this recording contract because the
primary driver for that record label or
whomever was we got to make this
marketable it has to be it has to we
have to aggregate as many eyeballs as
possible on this thing so that it sells
enough units to make us the most amount
of money possible yeah dude I see you
were Derek Siver's si and I raised you a
Seth Godin I would say go for it this
came out earlier today so I didn't even
think about reading this until you read
that one if the title of this is I'm not
selling anything so good this joke is
gonna be so funny Josh
[Laughter]
you know Ella says that to shut up the
title of this is I'm not selling
anything of course you are you're
selling connection or forward motion
you're selling a new way of thinking a
better place to work a chance to make a
difference or perhaps you're selling
possibility generosity or sheer hard
work it might be that the selling you're
doing costs time and effort not money
but if you're trying to make change
happen then you're selling something if
you're not trying to make things better
why are you here hmm so sure you're
selling something perhaps it would be
more accurate to say I'm not selling
something too aggressively
invading your space stealing your
attention and pushing you to do
something that doesn't match your goals
that's probably true at least I hope it
is I think that's the thing with like so
we're we've gone on tour we really hope
people show up you're out on tour right
now Paul and you want people to show up
you're selling yourself you're selling
this performance you're selling your
music you hope people listen to it but
you're also asking for more than just
money quite often we're asking for the
most precious resource someone's
attention yeah absolutely
time and attention and dude I gotta say
man if I'm going out of my way
to get someone's attention then I'm
going to make the most of that time yeah
I'm gonna otherwise you're wasting their
time absolutely
what's your pithy answer Ryan my Pitts
the answer is forcing yourself to make
money from a hobby is a great way to
kill your love for that hobby and going
back to what I was trying to get out of
you earlier about there was this point
in your career man where you were
forcing yourself to make money because
you wanted to get out of that that
nine-to-five job which there's nothing
wrong with wanting to to do something
different but when we force ourselves to
make money we start to compromise a lot
of things that that we normally wouldn't
compromise it yes and in my case the
irony was that the thing that people
connect was was is the thing that I was
compromising to make it a career and so
and when I basically wedges I redefine
success at that pour I'm like
it's okay I may have to do some things
that I don't want to do too you know
have a roof over my head but I don't
want to lose the thing that I love
anymore and so it's okay if I have to do
those things but to protect that my new
definition of success in music is gonna
be working at Home Depot so that I have
my nights free you know to make music
and then that love that that took all
the pressure off to make commercially
viable stuff and then now I think it's
the authenticity the honesty that people
end up connecting with and I end up
writing differently and just sort of
took that that demon off my shoulder you
know when I was when I was in the room
and and it became my job after this I
mean I still although it's what it's how
I make money now if music is still my
hobby - it's what I do
you know for felt like a lot of people
say well how do you you know how do you
write a record a year just I'm like it's
literally what I do for fun like I you
know I'll go home and all it's cheaper
than therapy a lot of times and you know
I it's just it's just one of the ways
that I most enjoy myself it's so true
man it's funny because I think about
what what you and I do Josh and I'm
still having fun and people I know they
look at us and they're like me and the
minimalists are so huge now and in in
their fame and whatever people tell us
but dude I still fully expect one day
we're gonna wake up and the rug is just
gonna be like swept out from underneath
us in fear or the people can be like oh
like you know what you know the wrong
door right exactly like yeah exactly
like oh no we did not mean to buy that
album went to the wrong address all
right then we're gonna get like you know
a hundred thousand books returned to us
system but ultimately though you know
going to the thing that Josh and I
talked about where you know Josh and I
truly feel like over the last eight
years like you know one of the super
powers we've been able to develop is is
letting go and and I am totally willing
to let go of making money this way just
like you are willing of letting go of
making money that way but it's something
that you always want to do and that's
how I feel about it like this is
something I'm always going to
incorporate in my life it's something
I'm always going to be passionate and
excited about and I can make money off
of it great but but tomorrow I might not
but as long as I can go find for me it's
being a barista my definition of success
is like you know one day Josh we
actually might be able
to be baristas I mean if all this falls
apart you have that coffee shop I know
that's like our plant that's like our
plan D I don't know weaver would let us
work
we own a coffee shop not allowed to
touch anything you own a coffee shop
when like people come over and like it
let me make you a cup of coffee uh yeah
the explanations are super hot well well
the thing is you come to my house and I
make you a cup of coffee you're gonna
have an awesome cup of coffee okay
that's so but the problem is a lot of
people like because they know we own a
coffee shop they'll send us like bags of
beans and the intentions are always
great but it'd be like if I wrote a song
for you to say thanks for writing songs
and and it's like you would appreciate
the sentiment but it would be so bad
you're nothing like four chords man like
really well but you're not going to put
and and so yeah I mean even like okay
like thanks like but you'd have to lie
sort of soldier through the experiences
of me thanking you that one we got
another question right Ryan we do it's
from little nibble did you write this
Josh don't you know every single
voicemail and we get up and Twitter from
me I just disguise my voice and we're
mustaches
I like the mustache part because you
don't even need that it's just again the
carrot go for it
alright little nibble once the note do
you think one or two good hobbies are
essential for a happy mind why gets 400
how many do you think it is boss two
options one or two so one or two hobbies
what do you think what do you think
hobbies are essential for a happy mind
happy mine I I think that things things
that you do for the pure joy of it are
if and if that be the definition of a
hobby then then yes but uh I think it's
a great definition for a hobby a hobby
is something you do for pure joy minimal
maximum right there mr. Harding however
that being said I think that happiness I
think pursuing happiness is a fool's
errand I am and I think that you will
not
I think that I think that if the goal is
to get happy you will not get happy and
so it's it's a but you will feel like
you got really close you always feel
like you get close you're right around
the bend right you always almost did it
but uh but so so I don't know I mean
it's on one side you know like I love
taking walks I love hiking and that
brings me brings me joy but but I don't
think I go ahead and go out and walk
thinking like this is gonna make me
really really happy like I think it's
usually like I need some clarity I just
need a moment or I need some exercise
and then in that moment of presence I
become happy but um I don't know I mean
if it's not the expectation yeah I'm
with you
yes so if the question is are hobbies
essential for a happy mind my pithy
answer is just three words essential is
perspectival and so like what's
essential for me like because ryan has
hot plenty of hobbies that I don't have
he likes mountain biking and
snowboarding and I like walking and
writing and like there's there can be
intersect like we wait you what do you
ride right Oh what the hell are you into
that's a different episode oh I'm back
so I need to start our own podcast talk
about stuff we can't talk about on here
yeah Ryan will you got anything pithy
for me oh yeah man I was just gonna say
hobbies hobbies aren't the way to
happiness but they do make life
interesting so going back to relying on
happiness Paul I'm so shocked dude like
you you have taken a hobby you've turned
it into a living you do what you love
and you mean to tell me that you still
have to work you mean there are days
where you still have to get up and work
oh absolutely and it's I'm not a good
worker that's that's the issue is I'm
I'm actively trying to hire out the work
right now
of so you can fascinate or what is that
it's yeah well it's procrastination and
it what to do the work he loves man like
and it's impossible for him to take
pictures while he's doing this podcast
and do the podcast at the same time we
got Thomas in the room yeah but there's
there's definitely days when you know
you just you just don't feel like it or
or that the things that go around and
supporting it you know or like the admin
work and that kind of stuff but I mean
at the end of the day if if that's my
version of you know the Home Depot and
that sort of you know that that
definition of doing that so that the
music can be protected I'm happy to do
it there's there's I forgot the book but
um I think was called big magic I forgot
the who wrote it but it was basically
saying like the it's not the arts job to
take his Gilbert yeah yeah absolutely
and as I said is it's not the arts job
to take care of you it's your job to
take care of the art and and that we
really turned around its I'm gonna stop
trying to extract from the art what I
need to like live my life but I'm gonna
I'm gonna get the things I need however
I need to get them so I can take care of
the art and and that was a big mindset I
see a huge that's great that's also a
great pithy one that we sold from Liz
there she did get was a really nice
blurb once upon a time and so yeah we
owe you one Thank You Liz
one more question here Larry asked
baseball cards comic books guitars
spoons stamps shot glasses etc
collecting isn't a hobby is it and if
you want to hear our answer to that
question then you have to tune into our
PostScript episode this week's every
week Ryan and I record a little
PostScript episode it's it's the the PS
of the podcast a really short episode
it's a it's called the minimalist
private podcast and it shows up right
there in your podcast feed so you don't
have to get on the Internet log into
some weird account and then I forgot my
password where's my password manager and
all these other things this is where the
logging into the internet show comes
yeah you have to log onto the internet
you don't have to get out your 56k modem
it shows so if you're listening to this
podcast on your phone right now you can
also listen to our PostScript episode
right there on your phone same podcast
player you listen to if you are a
patreon supporter so each each episode
each week we put out an episode of the
minimalist private podcast it's sort of
a follow up question we also do a bunch
of other stuff for our patreon
supporters so if you are a patreon
supporter you get access to our what we
call ask the minimalists anything every
month Ryan and I do a video livestream
for our patreon supporters we also put
out some of our live events there on
patreon on the minimalist private
podcast so we did this episode with I've
said we it was Ryan because I was sick
right with Paul and then with Cal
Newport and I think we're gonna chop
that one up and extract the the good
bits from that we'll put that there are
some really good bits yeah
there are also some not really good and
plus you you you play some flavor I
apologize you played my favorite like
this you play my favorite song live in
front of almost a thousand people there
ought to do yeah and so we'll make sure
that makes its way to the the
minimalists private podcast as well if
you're interested in supporting us you
can just go over to the minimalists com
click on donate at the top you can
support us on PayPal or venmo one-time
contributions we really appreciate that
or if you want to become a regular
supporter and have access to all the
backend stuff the live events the the
postscript podcasts the live streams
also we're gonna do a video tour of the
studio space and we put out Philadelphia
Tampa and Detroit those live events
recently as well those are all free if
you're one of our actually they're not
free right we're selling them to you in
a way by the way none of this money goes
to me or Ryan it goes to this beautiful
space that we're building up here and in
Los Angeles of tour we're gonna give you
a video tour for our patreon supporters
so head on over to the minimalists
column click donate at the top if you
want to support us and we should
probably move on Ryan to our added value
portion of the show let's do it so we
talked about usually talk about some of
this added value to our lives recently
but instead of doing that we've been
swooning over Paul the entire time so
maybe you play a song for us love to
have you blessed that be great man do
you have one you'd like to play or do me
to throw one out to you when I could if
there's one you wanna hear I'm happy to
do that I'm happy to yeah
I'll go either direction here what's
your satellite so oh no no that's not
here satellite practice that and so long
no way and so it you see your album
constellation I think the title comes
from that that that song right yeah yeah
yeah it's uh so I mean the the the album
title was in satellite is a kind of
marking on that it's basically just
about trying to put together the few
known points of a season a person a
thing and then recognizing that it's
it's eventually going to be a distortion
and and trying to adapt and then and at
trying to navigate those dark spaces in
between the points of light and
understanding you are going somewhere
but you know what we're not quite sure
where yet so sort of in that moment
suspension which I wish I had satellite
and like performance ready for it cuz
I'd be a great intro for it not
satellite will pick a song and then
we'll we'll have that live on the
podcast for everyone no Josh oh I
promise that if you keep your bra on
during this song I will keep my bran I
don't promise I'll keep mine so since
we're not going to listen to satellite
today how about the new single you have
out let's let's listen to the shadows
sounds great
[Music]
I heard and never rains in California
[Music]
every day just fades in the Yellow Sun
sets
maybe I should break away and drive as
it's been swaying
[Music]
it's good a time for me to Riga
[Music]
I had to find my way out of a bad dream
in the morning I came through snow
Bibles it's my bloodstream
I couldn't see I snitch
[Music]
who wants it
[Music]
head up from the shell girls through the
night
you are two miles a darkness you still
are the deal is done it's time field
line
[Music]
it's time to feel like
[Music]
say Happy Endings weave off
[Music]
it's always gonna be another battle to
fight
we feel that the stories go
all the heroes died
I won't blink pain
[Music]
from the shed girls through the night
[Music]
Oh
you are two miles a divers you still VD
is done it's time to feel
it's time to fear
[Music]
it's time
[Music]
hi
go ahead up from the shadows girl
[Music]
you are two miles and us you steady
[Music]
it's time to feel like
it's time fear
[Music]
dude that line about uh uh if you let
the story go long enough
yeah the heroes die i text with you the
day came out I'm like oh my god yeah no
I was just gonna say for me dude it's uh
it's a reminder to live in the moment
because instead of worrying about a
legacy instead of worrying about what
I'm gonna be in 20 years
dude how long enough timeline I'm dead
the hopefulness earlier there's the
optimism in the following line but I'm a
blank page and I'm ready to write
absolutely and and there's just
something like we embrace the blank page
or we can be terrified by the blank page
and there were certainly the opposite
there where it's like it's optimistic
and yeah and there's a bright future on
the blank page that Sean thank you so
much thank you for the opportunity to
play it and it just means so much that
uh that's you guys uh let me do that if
I know you don't tour a whole lot and
kudos to you for that man we've learned
our lesson eight times over one of our
favorite musicians from the band parlor
Hawk the he did the lead singer of the
band parlor Hawk it's my favorite album
of all time is their their self-titled
second album he did the soundtrack to
our documentary and just just so tell
like his voice is an instrument his
name's Andrew and man he doesn't tour at
all anymore because I just like I've
liked creating I don't I don't like toy
but you you found seems like a
comfortable balance of both you're out
on the road right now it's definitely I
mean I love I love getting to meet the
people that allow me to do this for a
living and that kind of stuff but I also
definitely need to take the moments to
to create and and just to like we were
talking about before just kind of inhale
a bit and all that good stuff and also
right now I'm just in a moment of like
like 2017 was was immense what about I
don't know if this is you know this may
be just kind of beyond a
what we're recording a cow thing but
like 2017 was was a period of growth for
Kane City and out 2018 I'm sort of
having to struggle with a moment of like
quote saying this is enough like this is
um you know like I'm gonna exactly I
found myself over the last six months
decreasing and happiness as numbers and
things were increasing and I was like
why is that like I get to do what I
absolutely love to do things are better
than they've ever been but I'm getting
sadder and sadder and I'm treating
people poorer and poorer is it because
it's raising your expectations well yeah
well it was with every it was the fear
of lose I ever before this I had nothing
to lose and then it was the fear of
losing or having something to lose and
then also with everything that would
happen to be like okay now we have to
sustain and we have to grow and so now
2018 is really a moment where I'm like
like draw a line and say this is enough
and we hope of course you always you
always welcome growth but if if this is
if this is where you know the cruising
altitude then that is seven times what I
ever would expect or hope for and and
and in that I'm starting to finally be
able to enjoy it and not be so scared
all the time due to me this is where the
the idea of Home Depot bein like Plan B
or Plan C whatever it is like to me like
that's where I would that's where I do
use that that tactic man like I feel the
same way it's like I don't get more
depressed the more that the minimalists
grow but I feel the pressure I feel I
feel the pressure of like everything I
say has to be profound every
conversation I have especially if it's
at an event or if it's like an actual
like fan I have to change their life
with the conversation that I end like I
put all this pressure on myself to do
more to do more and I have to remind
myself like a Ryan what you guys have
been doing is what's what has gotten you
this far so keep doing that and then I
do remind myself B if it all goes the
[ __ ] yeah I can go be a barista yeah
maybe they'll let me touch the espresso
machine
and so I think it's a very unhuman and
especially on american thing i love
america nope no you know like not trying
to dig there but like we all love
america i think it's pretty safe there's
an American mindset that you're set yeah
yeah very very American mindset very
Western mindset of life it's funny how
Western Western mindset is code for dumb
American mindset like I don't want to
piss anybody off but an American mindset
of like always always building always
growing I was expanding and then it was
sort of like the bigger it got the
harder it was to to be happy because
like the hot the more I had to like you
know achieved like top that and and and
it was the happiness was tied to topping
what I did yesterday and so I'm
currently in a moment I still don't feel
like I've perfected I'm currently in a
moment of defining like this I'm okay
here and I'm actually okay with half of
this but and and like now I can be like
finally present and grateful and you
know and trying to get better at that
that's beautiful well I hope everyone
checks out your new single I hope they
check out the albums and go back to the
catalog and and just listen and pause
when necessary
hahaha I appreciate that all right so
let's move on to right here right now so
where we talk about what's going on in
the lives of the minimalists the day
this comes out we are in Australia Ryan
how about that event in Perth oh my god
there was so much somebody flies how do
you develop an accent so quickly how do
you not man I have simulate two cultures
why aren't you tolerant enough have you
tried saying bacon yet in an Australian
accent I have tried to say beer can in
the Jamaican accent that sounds similar
no but we we already had events in Perth
and Adelaide
my guess is those already actually you
know what let me pull up the tour page
real quick Ryan so we were doing seven
events in Australia I'm looking at this
right now
we already did Perth we did Brisbane the
day this comes out we'll be in Sydney
that's probably already sold out at the
time looking at this there's only a few
tickets left anyway so it's I think it's
our biggest stop of the entire tour this
year almost 2,000 people there
Adelaide you are so popular it's all
humans the hair and that fake mustache
you're wearing we're gonna be an
Adelaide that's probably also sold out
let's March 15th and then Auckland there
are a few tickets left in Auckland New
Zealand and we're coming back to do
Melbourne as the kids are saying these
days and I say kids I mean Australian
kids we're gonna be in Melbourne we have
two events the first ones already sold
out the second one by the time this
comes out may or may not be sold out you
can find all the tickets for our March
dates in Australia and New Zealand over
at the minimalists com we also have a
video version of this podcast coming
really soon so once we have enough
patreon supporters so thank you to all
of our patreon supporters your help
means a lot because it's going to allow
us to do a a video version of the
podcast buy all the necessary equipment
and we're in this beautiful space right
now because of you and it's sounding
really crisp and clear because you're
allowing us to buy the equipment we need
so if you want to check out the video
version of the podcast head on over to
youtube.com slash the minimalists also
if you want all the show notes that we
always talk about everything we talked
about during the podcast podcast Shaun
puts into the show notes for you we'll
send those right to your email just go
to our website and enter your email
address there at the top of the
minimalists comm also any new essays or
anything that we write we will put it
out in your inbox as well but of course
will never put spam into your inbox
because that stuff's disgusting we would
never sell your email address or
anything like that
I Ryan you got anything else for us I do
I've got some awesome voice mail
comments and tips from our listeners hi
my name is Kaylee from st. Paul
Minnesota this message is for Ryan in
recent well lost her dad to fears that a
couple years ago and recently called in
I have a feeling that she is angry about
maximalist because she doesn't want her
father's death to be in vain
I too lost my dad to suicide almost
eight years ago and you want their death
to mean something it's so tragic that
you want it to have a point you don't
want to have just lost a loved one for
no reason and so here is what you focus
on it is not in vain that they died
because now you are aware of issues that
can lead to suicide and you can now
spread awareness education and help
reduce the stigma around it no matter
the cause it needs to be it talked about
extremely more than it is right now so
he did not die in vain he did not take
it on life for no reason and you will
get past it time will help but doing
what you can do to talk about it and
help others who go through the situation
will help bring you peace as well I hope
I hope time will heal all room you'll
never forget but it will get better I
promise
hello this is Megan I am 27 from Tempe
Arizona and I just had a comment so I
just got a divorce
of a divorce and had to move into a
one-bedroom apartment I previously lived
in a three-bedroom house with lots and
lots of stuff and when I moved I decided
I would only take the essentials with me
and so now I'm in a very empty apartment
I don't even have a couch I've been
sitting on the living-room floor but my
comment was I have made a list of the
things that I want to buy for the
apartment and I am waiting two weeks for
any item that has been added to the list
and the list Earl everything has a date
on it from when it's added so that I
know that I'm waiting enough time to see
if it's something that I actually need
or if it's something that I can go
without hi my name is Astrid and I'm
from Sydney I'd like to leave a tip for
kaitland who spoke on the emotions
episode about overthinking and judging I
feel that our goals can be linked to
self judgment and shame if they are not
achieved perfectly we can have ongoing
self-criticism as a result and
experience rumination about it my tip is
to think about what you might say to a
friend
who was experiencing the same
difficulties for example if a friend was
overthinking her performance about an
exam and feeling stressed would I
criticize and shame them or as a good
friend would I show patience kindness
and encouragement Katelyn might also try
approaching herself as she would a
friend who have this difficulty treating
herself like a friend Katelyn might be
looking for external things to make her
happy
for example achieving certain marks on
an exam but might want to instead focus
on developing internal resources such as
kindness and self compassion to make her
feel better
Katelyn can Google self compassion and
find many activities and exercises to
increase this personal resource alright
y'all that's it for this episode if you
have a question for the minimalists give
us a call for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine you can also
email a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists comm and if you leave here
with just one message we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time